well i've heard of that of certain
people like um graduate students or
something just thriving on that deadline
whereas if they have a long time to work
on let's say
a paper that they won't do it but
knowing that they have a week left
that there's just some kind of
adrenaline rush that they get that is
that the same for you like if you know
you have let's say 10 things
in the ether that you're going to be
working on how does that feel
that that pressure because i like it i
mean every paper i wrote in college
was i did not read the books all
semester or
quarter didn't look at the work and
starting at about 1am
the night before it was due i wrote the
paper and read the books and skimmed the
things and
every single one every test how i
studied for it the ones the papers that
my mom didn't write for me she did write
something for me
um very nice and that's probably
technically called cheating but you know
whatever
if your mom writes for i think it's okay
i proof read it sure
translate it into my own typing because
you didn't like the type
okay he's a handwriter nice get a caller
and be like mom i cannot read your
writing if you're gonna write papers for
me can be a little bit more crisp in
your
penmanship um but it just feels good i i
like
the pressure i enjoy feeling knowing on
set that i have a whole production
that's depending on me to deliver it's
exciting for me
that's interesting when did you realize
that about yourself because i i
realized the same about myself but it
wasn't until i read this article and
like i don't know psychology today or
something that
people do there's a certain sect of the
population that
thrives on that pressure when was it
that you realized that
i think i realized i think i always knew
that i liked pressure in my head there
was a weird conundrum that formed
because
i also had a pretty severe speech
problem growing up so i couldn't even
speak and i hated the pressure of being
called on
for many years of my life i couldn't
even like i didn't want a teacher to ask
me to speak in class
so i knew that i wanted to be an
entertainer and a performer and i could
make people laugh when i was able to
speak fluently
but when it wasn't those times i was
sitting there like deathly afraid of
being called on a nervous and locked
down with my vocal cords
and just tense and and
frozen and so it was a weird dichotomy
but i knew that i had to break out of
that to fulfill what i wanted for my
life and just eventually i did
is that where the being funny came in
because i know a lot of times people
develop that as a coping mechanism for
stuff so is that i don't think so
i don't think it was i mean it probably
helped me be funnier i guess just you
know
more so because it forced me i was a
talker as a kid and
you know before my speech problem came
out at age like three i was talking a
million miles a minute
and i found some home video myself
recently and it was like frightening
how fast i was talking and so i think
maybe
the world you know forced me to shut up
and listen and observe
and i think that may have helped my
observations of the world
and the way i saw things but i think
since i was a kid i always saw the world
in a weird
comedic lens i just would see ridiculous
things adults were doing or decisions
that the world would be making
collectively it seemed and they always
seemed
full of folly and they were being you
know decided in a very
odd flawed logic system and so i thought
it was
you know if you don't point out the
humor in those things it's just gonna be
maddening so
i decided you know i just didn't decide
but it's just naturally filtered through
my brain in a
in a humorous way that's the most boring
answer possible for an answer
answer about how funny i am well
another idea sparked while you were
saying that and that is in those moments
when you maybe had to get up in front of
the class and you were dreading maybe
the kids
around you and as mean as kids can be
how did that then later groom you for
let's say being on chelsea lately or
things because you seem so
confident and funny and
is that where some of that came from
like is that a good school for you
totally you know growing up around
bullies you know making fun of you for a
speech problem
certainly helped prepare me for chelsea
handler bullying me on the air
in a friendly way but she made you know
a good part of that show about making
fun of me and everything i would say or
do so i definitely had built up a pretty
strong
shield against that kind of thing and i
was able to take it in a way that i
think most people would not enjoy being
made fun of and i loved it and thrived
and
because i developed to a point where i
you know had such a good sense of humor
about myself i think that i could
just joke about whatever and take it and
uh
i used to love watching johnny carson
and charles grodden or letterman and
grodden argue and
grown to be a guest and they'd had this
contentious energy but you knew there's
a friendship behind it but
it was just this very like aggressive to
me it's just so funny to have an
interview
or an interview we angry at each other i
just love that dynamic i always wanted
to do that on tv so i got to do that
um yeah i think i think having having
built that up i mean chelsea even made
fun of my speech problem on the air a
bunch
uh not my stutter i'd overcome that but
i stole the lisp to this day a little
bit of a lisp
and she enjoyed putting that out but it
used to be a source of pain
it became a source of humor to me
because i realized we can laugh at we
all have issues we have things wrong
with us and it's fun
to laugh at ourselves and she was always
able to laugh at herself too and
didn't mind if you threw stuff back at
her you know i always thought that maybe
she wouldn't want that for the first
bunch of years in the show i wouldn't
throw stuff back at her and then one day
we were hanging out and i said to her
like
do you mind if i sometimes throw stuff
vacuum sometimes i'm like censoring
myself when i want to
throw an insult back your way cause i
don't know if you'd like it she's like
whoever said you can't throw something
back on me
and i said well when you you know have
this bravado in the hallways and act as
though
you know you miss chelsea handler
walking out there um
you kind of give up the impression that
you don't want people to be able to
throw stuff back at you as well and
she's like oh that was not my intention
i
ignore everybody in the hallways you can
say whatever you want and she meant it
and i started the last
couple seasons throwing stuff back at
her and her banter got so much better
and it's just so much more freeing so
if you can ditch it you have to be able
to take it and she certainly could and i
can
too i make fun of people constantly on
idiot tests and in my stand up and
on twitter so if i can't take it that
would be hypocritical
i get a lot of hate these days on
twitter i've found
with the success you get a much larger
amount of
negative responses and people reacting
weirdly to things that you do and i
think it's very funny i
often favorite insults on twitter
i will engage people that call me idiots
um
because i call people idiots and i'm
still fans of theirs
so it would be stupid if i couldn't you
know also you're not doing anything
interesting if you're not
offending and annoying some people i
think i've too much of my career was
worried about
being
inoffensive or making sure that i
wouldn't you know be doing anything that
was
too you know jarring to any one group
and
they just been letting go of so much of
that and i think you know
through that comes a lot of freedom you
know the reason i became a stand-up was
george carlin he's my favorite comedian
ever and
i saw some interview with him and every
few months when i forget this i ended up
on the internet down the rabbit hole the
internet and i keep re-stumbling on this
video this interview with george carlin
where
they asked him what made him truly
success and he said when he when he
finally stopped
caring what people thought of him is
when he truly started to find success
and i'm finding the same to be true um
yeah that's the end of that answer